Welcome home.
Hi.
It is I, the great Minky.
It is I.
Oh, hiyao.
Hello, hello.
It's Ghost Made Minto.
Yes.
We are back with To the Moon, part two.
Part two, baby.
Yeah, we'll finish the game today.
I don't know, maybe we'll cry.
Oh, hey yo, oh hey yo.
To the Moon.
Two of them.
Two of the Moon.
We're cloning.
The story's going to take a wild twist.
rather than going to the moon, they're actually going to clone the moon.
It's like, it's, it's, uh...
You know, meteor?
Like that.
We're gonna make the dinosaurs meteor.
Except this, it's like we're going to the moon.
And...
And someone says, yeah, we're going to the moon.
you're like no we're going to two of them the mood what's bro on about are you getting it crazy turn or maybe I've heard that this game has sequels which I don't quite understand how but maybe that's what happens in the sequel is
After going to the moon, you'd see on the dark side of the moon, there's been a second moon the whole time.
Actually, doesn't Earth have like a small little moon, second moon right now?
Spoilers?
My bad.
I don't know what she's cooking, but she's cute.
Bravo, Kojima.
For a couple months.
Yeah.
little while we have a second moon I wasn't paying attention you have two moons yeah just like when I say I have four cheeks thank you so much for the five thank you thank you thank you thank you two moons too furious I was thinking they could bring the moon down if he fails.
The astronaut exam.
Cloning the moon somehow feels safer.
We're gonna make Legend of Zelda happen.
We're gonna bring the moon to me.
Bring it here.
We're gonna bring it down.
Bring her home.
We're gonna make a big old crater for the moon.
Where should we put her?
Oh, sorry, I was yawning.
You're going to trigger a time loop then?
Oh my gosh, my favorite.
Humanity is doomed.
I got this.
I can tank it.
I've got a barn you could use for the moon.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
We'll put it in Neckowulf 583's barn.
The moon.
And if anybody has a problem with that, I'm talking to you, the tides of the ocean.
We're just not even gonna address the problem.
Are we ready to complete to the moon?
We'll get all the jokes out of the way, I guess, because the game is about to get super sad?
Maybe.
Good day, Minto.
It appears I survived the super typhoon.
Let's go!
Thank you for personally protecting the Philippines.
Santo Minto.
You're welcome.
I did that.
Beware the phantom moon.
Callistry, welcome back to Memmoonship.
Everything is moon today.
We're ready?
It's moon in time?
Actually, that got my sister expelled from school.
She mooned her teacher.
The moontide is tugging on our hearts right now.
What kind of cheese is the moon made of?
Everybody says swish, but...
What, really?
Yeah, really.
Yeah.
She didn't... I don't know if she liked the teacher or not.
I can't remember.
But she was like, hey!
And then mooned him.
And she got in big trouble.
Wednesday is my birthday!
Scuba Gator!
I'm sorry!
I'll just sing, but if you don't want to, but could you maybe tell me that the age of 38 is in demand that I'm not old yet?
Scuba Gator!
The age of 38 is in demand and you are not old yet.
Honestly, honestly, you can subtract like five years from that because of COVID.
So it's like you're not that age.
And also, it's how you feel in your Kokoro.
If you are young-hearted, then it's fine.
Oh, thanks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it'll just keep going.
Is that how COVID works?
Dragon Slayer, thank you so much for the gift.
Sort of fulfilling his dream to the moon, we'll turn it into a nightmare.
Good evening, Mito.
Has anyone told you you're extra cute today?
What did I do?
What was it, the fries I ate earlier?
You are strong, we'll be proud.
Super Tomam, welcome to Mambushab Taku!
Taku, Taku!
is doomed now humanity is moaned humanity is moaned on a phantom is just as freaky as minky yeah it does i guess maybe run in the family okay so last time let's give a brief recap last time we met we're we're a pair of scientists we went to this old guy's house and he's he's dying he's he's not gonna make it he's not gonna make it he's old it happens i don't know but he signed up for this program where they go into your brain and they give you like a false memory l grams i got old ones no no don't do it don't do it don't do it i promise you don't do it no thank you so much for the take after it thank memory of you accomplishing a wish.
So they go through all your old memories and then influence your past old memory self to push them forward towards a different goal so that ultimately in your more recent memories you have accomplished that goal while you're laying on your deathbed.
That's sketchy.
It sounds so morally wrong.
When you, like...
When you really say it, it sounds like so...
It's like a dying wish.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
Thank you for the gift strangers.
Everybody's so generous.
Thank you guys so much.
I would like to offer you one last.
Before you hit the road tomorrow.
Thank you, Grandpa!
I will be bringing my stuff.
So, I will be able to stream more than I thought I would be able to able to.
I also was kind of worried since a lot of flights were getting canceled and stuff.
I was like, if I have to stay a couple extra days, I definitely would want to stream at the hotel.
So, um, yes.
So uh, uh, this, this, this, like maybe Friday, Saturday, Sunday, you'll get streams.
That's the plan at least.
So, they might be odd times, so I apologize in advance, but yeah, yeah, yeah.
My advice for the day, be cool like Minto!
Yeah!
So.
These are odd times.
Yeah, they are.
Tomorrow's my birthday!
General Dank!
Oh my gosh!
birthday.
Oh my gosh, you're still around.
Thank you.
Stuck at the airport right now.
Oh, geez, I hope your flight's not delayed so much.
So far, so far it says it's okay.
So I guess I'll see you tomorrow.
I guess I'll see you tomorrow.
But what I was saying, so they do these things where they implant the false memory or whatever and fulfill your dying wish.
but but it's not working for some reason and we turned into little wisps and we had to do a bunch of move but connecting connecting the dots for some reason it didn't work so we're figuring that out that's where we ended hello me though hello since 15 minutes ago I'm officially another year older probably not that much wiser.
Thanks for being here.
You generally, genuinely, genuinely an inspiration and the community you've built is a major positive part of my everyday life.
Lots of love.
Nashi, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Thank you so much!
Well, then we shouldn't waste any more time.
It's not like you're getting any younger.
Let's do the game.
Let's go back in.
why is it so scary okay so we figured we don't know why it's not working we don't know why let's see to the moon darling we have planted like all these things like hey we'll go watch this movie about going to the moon and all this stuff my birthday's in like two months can I get a happy birthday too I feel Brayden,
no!
Don't be...
Don't be hasty.
I will see you in two months.
To the moon!
Maybe it's a bad movie, right?
Ooh, Henry!
Dear Lord, I'm way too tired and hungry to be constructing movies.
Guess I should go see if anything's changed with John.
Yeah, it's a bad movie, I think.
Sorry for making you sit through this, buddy.
Oh.
So it was a bad movie.
Need to check on John.
It's all the same.
He hasn't gone to the moon even once.
I'll have to try igniting it somewhere else then.
This is ridiculous.
How dare he see one movie once about...
Okay.
You know...
As a kid, though, you do get really easily influenced about these kinds of things.
You'll, like, see a movie about, like...
See animals and you'll be like, I'm gonna be a marine biologist.
You know, okay, I get it, but at the same time, 10 months of freaky ghost made.
Thank you!
My birthday's in 45 minutes.
Whoa, Sanga!
I wish you a happy birthday in 45 minutes, just tell me.
Lily?
Reach into your brain.
Oh, okay.
This is when he asks her out.
Perhaps something here could work.
I'll only go out with you, John, if you go to the mood.
That's what...
That's what she'll say.
I don't have time for her right now.
Okay, just kidding.
Implant the bees.
So did she throw an encyclopedia in your face?
Huh?
Did she?
Gotta eat dinner.
Okay.
See you after dinner.
Shut up, dude.
What are you guys doing here?
It's starting.
Let's go get a good spot.
What's starting?
Wait, I don't remember that happening.
Something must have changed.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, the children are going outside.
Hey, don't squeeze.
Wait, hold on.
Who are these kids?
Nobody.
We don't care about them.
We're going outside.
We've changed it.
We've changed the past.
Is it...
It's like a...
That's the auditorium?
So maybe a show?
Wait a minute.
This isn't a real change.
This is...
May I...
Oh, it's him!
Oh, gosh.
It's Neil.
May I have your attention, please?
As you know, I am a representative sent from NASA in all its glory.
Disney's actually done stuff like that.
Over a year before Finding Nemo, they put fun facts about fish in the bumpers on Disney Channel.
So that by the time the movie was being advertised, kids liked fish.
The subliminal advertising is crazy.
Hey kids, want to learn about a fish?
Oh my gosh, though!
I learned about...
Oh gosh, what's the fish called?
Hold on.
I can look him up.
And I will remember.
It's a fish with a very tragic life.
Sad guy.
The tripod fish.
The tripod fish is so sad.
oh my gosh someone else is also basically they're born and then they like have this like camouflage mechanism that allows them to look like a jellyfish but then they lose that for some reason and then they start sinking to the bottom of the ocean and their limbs start extending like they start growing these like spiny looking things out their fins and they lose the ability to swim.
And they just have to stand still at the bottom of the ocean.
And so that makes them really popular to like parasites too.
And they're already at the bottom of the ocean.
Unable to move much.
And there's not much food down there for them to eat.
And it's just horrible.
I don't understand why it evolved like that.
Like what?
Why?
Evolutionary...
Disinvantages.
Disinvantages, yes.
It's quite strange, but it's also very fascinating, and they're very cute, I think.
I would look them up, the tripod fish.
Greenland sharks are basically Dark Souls lore.
Oh no!
I'm gonna have to look that up later.
Okay, back to game, sorry.
And I'm here to tell you all about it!
Okay, we're learning about NASA!
Let's go.
Hit it, Timmy!
Oh, oh.
Oh, okay.
Wow, that was terrible.
But I digress.
Anyway.
Anyways, I know that many of you are wondering.
What chances do slash have of doing something as awesome as adventuring in another realm?
Venus to swim counterclockwise through the rings of Saturn or perhaps just chilling at the backside of the man Oh, that was an italicized eye
Oopsie I thought it was a timeout I
thought it was a typo.
Because what chances do...
What chance do slash have?
Wait, no, it was like, What chance do slash have?
Worst letter, do I italicize?
I agree, like at least make it lowercase and not an...
Do slash have
It does make total sense Anyway Well here at NASA we believe that enough will Everyone has the potential It could be you Or you No it's not going to be any of these kids or perhaps You But I don't want to go to the moon.
Then you're in love.
Wait, what?
Why not?
Why should I?
Thank you so much for that 20 get that.
Thank you!
I'm trying to, like, read your name.
No.
No name.
Thank you.
I'm happy here on Earth as it is.
Well, don't you want to go there even a little bit?
No, why?
Not even a tiny bit?
Um, no?
This kid's stubborn.
Well, as an official NASA recruiter, I shall go over some facts about the moon.
Okay, I think if all else fails, you just kidnap him in the dream.
And then, he is forced to go to the moon.
To start off, the moon is 4.5 billion years old.
This kid kind of sucks.
And did you know that its surface is about as big as Africa?
Emissary Zero and to the moon lore has some connection?
Oh, maybe.
It's true.
In fact, if you try to bike around the moon, okay, he's like giving all the boring facts.
Also, it takes 1.5247 seconds for light to travel to the moon from here.
And if you drive a flying car, it takes 130 days.
I knew that.
No, you didn't.
And last but not least, people who go to the moon get rich and famous!
Good luck!
Good luck with your exam!
Good luck with your exam.
And we all know that rich plus famous equals groupies.
So, that concludes my presentation.
Remember, NASA welcomes any of you, especially if you're a brunette.
Abduction to the moon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
That was terrible.
Well, what did you think?
NASA probably wouldn't hire you, but I suppose it was blatant enough for this.
Hmm, I do try pretty hard.
Are you gonna go see if that worked?
Of course.
Be right back.
Back.
Report.
Utter failure.
Deuce?
Is that how you spell that?
Hey, don't get discouraged.
I'm sure there are still things to be done.
Such as...
Well?
Thank
you, guys.
I can't afford to finish building this house, Isabel.
They can barely afford...
But you can't afford the Lunar Trip Lottery!
If you sell this house, you sure can!
Oh my god.
This is not a horror game, though.
Yes, in fact, we rarely have any...
Did you know that NASA has excellent healthcare plans?
It's true!
For both you and your spouse.
Free pony rides in space!
What are they doing?
Oh look, a wedding!
Good for you!
But here's a riddle.
Guess where you should go for your honeymoon.
Why are they doing that?
doing this.
NASA doesn't have parties anymore because they just can't find the time to plan it.
Hey Kiki!
Oh my gosh!
Hi.
River?
Isn't this like the traumatizing moment where she finds all the bunnies?
Oh my gosh.
Dagnabbit.
Glass.
Slippery.
Johnny.
John.
What the cucumber?
You know what?
This just isn't working.
It's more than just not working.
It's ridiculous.
We're freaking professionals.
I didn't sign up for the job to run around yelling at him like an idiot.
What the cucumber?
He didn't?
Look, maybe this lack of sleep's getting to us.
Had I known that we'd be...
We'd be an all-nighter.
I would have brought coffee.
I agree.
You should have seen the movie I constructed earlier.
What movie?
Exactly.
Anyway.
As valuable as time is here, this just isn't going anywhere like this.
Let's take a break till morning.
Hopefully Johnny can hang on till then.
Contagious yawns.
I'm sorry.
I'm the most if...
Oh, no, don't say yawn.
If someone says yawn, I yawn.
If someone yawns, I yawn.
I'm the worst at the... I... I literally will read the word yawn and I will yawn.
I'm the worst when it comes to contagious yawns.
I do have some calls to make.
I'm not gonna look at chat.
I see you guys.
I see you guys saying the word.
That wasn't a yawn, I was stretching my face.
Silently yawning?
When my cat...
When my cat yawns, I say that she's silently yelling at me.
She'll be like...
I'm like, why are you silently?
Don't stop yelling at me!
It doesn't make sense.
Why did the machine have no effect?
Johnny's registered wish to go to the moon was successfully transferred.
There wasn't even a trace of him wanting to go to the moon after the transfer.
Stop saying, Yon, please.
Unless...
Unless a secondary condition for the desire was changed in the process.
Only then, would the same desire produce two different outcomes at two different points in time.
I can't stop yawning!
I'm gonna smack myself awake.
Talk about yines.
If I could be yon, no yon!
No yon!
Someone kept telling me to go to the moon, I'd be off to the moon.
I'm right!
There's no denying that River played an important role through it all.
If there's anything that could have caused the core to change, she would be the top suspect.
But out of all things, what exactly caused it?
Just what exactly did you do?
Four-letter word that rhymes with brawn?
Prawn!
That's five letters.
Lawn!
Ah, the sun's rising.
I thought you were supposed to sleep!
What are you doing awake?
We don't have much time left.
Guys, we don't have much time left!
I wonder if Neil came up with anything.
I think it all has to do with river.
I think, I think, I think.
It was her dream or something.
Oh,
you can smell that squirrel And Yale ran over from all the way here now No, the squirrel Squirrel Squirrel Squirrel
Squirrel Oh, I'm going upstairs
Hello?
How is John doing?
Barely hanging on.
What are you two doing?
We just...
We just couldn't make any progress.
You'd better soon.
We don't have long.
If you're looking for your colleague...
I think he's in the kitchen.
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
The kitchen is here.
No, I understand that part, but...
Okay.
Did you confirm it in his records?
The bunny!
and why again was this information not made available to us or the medical doctor for that matter where did you get that coffee are you speaking with headquarters headquarters yes i'll fill you in after now shh
i thought i left this at johnny's bed oh yeah where did you find that you sh to me temporarily unshushed oh and i lucky well i found the rabbit in the lighthouse last night there's a bunch more of them there and in the basement too ah hmm all right resume shing okay i wonder what what was nods made to their attention i wonder oh yeah this is the clock that doesn't tick,
right?
Shhh!
I guess maybe...
She...
We can talk to her?
Ask her?
Oh.
Nope.
Still about the phone call.
Anything down here?
No.
Bone o'clock!
Oh yeah, baby.
If we can go to the basement, I suppose?
Um.
Oh.
But ma!
I don't wanna go to school.
It's Sunday, dear.
Shh.
Let them sleep.
Everybody's shushing me.
Can't speak at all to anybody.
I'm gonna turn the lights on.
Turn it off, you giant doofus.
No.
Look at them asleep!
It's kind of cute.
They're like heavy asleep.
Oh, yeah!
This is the Twilight book.
Read passage.
Please!
No!
Why won't you let me?
They want to silence me.
Is the light still on?
Oh my god.
What are you doing?
I really should have watched those two last night.
They were up late.
Well, it's not an everyday circumstance i suppose oh was there something you wanted to ask
lily unless i guess we can ask everything so lily you know it's pretty unusual for someone like you to work here with two children and all i mean sleeping in light mode so means it will it will it's getting their eyes adjusted to the world it's really it's not that bad really there's a school bus that passes through here.
How did you even end up here?
Well, a few years ago, my husband passed away.
What happened?
Oh, don't even say that I'm sorry.
He was in the army.
They were the last batch to be deployed overseas.
Sorry to hear.
I panicked.
Our savings were low when the job market was grim.
Johnny saw my ad and offered me this job.
I accepted with gratitude.
peaceful too.
Help me with my grieving.
Doesn't the government issue grants to war widows to help them get back on their feet?
They do.
And eventually, I received aid.
But by then, Johnny was starting to have trouble on his own.
He needed my help.
Tommy and Sarah liked this place too, and so we stayed.
As for Johnny, he was glad as well.
We're going to miss him.
I think deep down, he really wanted a family.
Aww.
Johnny.
So what are you going to tell them about John?
I don't know.
I'll probably make something up.
But it's no use.
Kids are smart nowadays.
They'll figure it out.
Johnny.
I just wanted to pass down his ideas.
Oh.
Might as well.
It's the nature of life.
There's nothing to hide.
Future.
This is your full-time job, isn't it?
What will you do when this is over?
What else is there to do?
Find a job in the city and live on, I suppose.
It's a shame, though.
I'm going to miss Johnny in this place.
Maybe I'll come back to visit every once in a while.
Oh, hey.
Yes.
Before Johnny fell unconscious, he told me that you two would probably be coming soon.
said that he probably wouldn't get the chance at himself but but he wanted to tell you thanks for he wanted me to tell you thanks for him so thank you oh we haven't even done our done it yet though oh geez oh geez oh uh let's go down here maybe
into like the freaky room
so freaky broken music box anything else no Johnny what's this what do we have here?
cabinet is filled oh that's right I think we checked this already I think so I think so the music stopping makes it even freaky here, I think.
It suddenly feels like a horror game.
Maybe we check the car?
Better go see if Neil has any ideas.
Just kidding.
We go see if Neil has any ideas.
Johnny just wanted to pass on his beans.
Uh-huh.
Oh.
Hmm.
What is it?
It seems like our little Johnny here has some hidden records from the old days.
Hidden records Hidden medical records to be exact Oh?
Apparently during his youth he was administered a large dose of enhanced beta blockers?
What is that?
The IPS And what luck they tend to have this little side effect on a curious thing called memories
Beta blockers Beta blockers Johnny didn't have a heart condition, did he?
Apparently not.
Which leads one to wonder.
If the side effects were intended to be merely just that to begin with.
And in such a large amount.
What?
Its impact on his memories at the time of administration must have been significant.
Huh?
You think that's what kept us out of his earliest memories?
Well, it's not the machine, I'll tell you that.
The Patriots?
The maintenance department yells at me for scolding them.
Oopsie.
So what now?
I know you use them at Project Zomboid to reduce panic.
I was just given the reconfiguration frequencies.
That should get us past the blockers.
And once we're in his childhood, it might finally be early enough to transfer his desire for it to work.
waiting for but just one thing what is it of course there's always that one thing in order sorry in order to activate the new frequencies we'll need a trigger bang bang bang pulled my johnny trigger something that exists strongly in the bridging inaccessible memory does anyone commented on this mgs1 background music only you rucks
And we'll need to give it to John for him to stimulate his memory internally.
But what do we know of that?
We've only gotten a glimpse of his childhood memories.
And even if we find a childhood photo or something, John's unconscious.
Yeah.
Back to square one.
In the soundtrack, this track is like one second long.
Bam, bam.
You know, this job hasn't been a pain in the earth.
arse for me since Nora's case last year.
Likewise.
What did Nora do?
This is killing me.
I'm going to get out to get some fresh air.
What did Nora do?
Oh!
Ahem.
Forgot my coffee.
Receive note.
Beta blocker.
The last paper rabbit river gave to John.
Bam bam It smells Quit barging in and out of doors Oh the roadkill Ava it smells I know it's your fault for running over it Wait Now the music is one It's like a little higher What's going on?
The children are still sleeping Wait a minute the one we were stuck at it was the same smell what are you two talking about the olfactory receptors are directly linked to the brain's limbic system Lily don't you see what this means what he means that smell is arguably the most effective sense for memory recall we can use it as the stimulant to bridge his childhood memories and the best part even though Johnny is unconscious he is still susceptible I think I'm missing some vital contextual info on this whole thing the dead squirrel is the key all right this is good this is awesome now you just need to go fetch a piece of the roadkill oh me why should I why should slash fetch
Why did I say slash before?
Oh my gosh.
You're the one who ran it over.
Exactly.
I've already done my part.
Oh, you miserable bastard.
Um, if it helps any, I...
Sorry, my throat doesn't hurt today.
For some reason, I have a cough, though.
I have a pair of gloves you can borrow.
Why just a piece?
would it be safer to bring the whole thing just throw it yeah grab the squirrel by the tail and throw it on his head we aren't really disposable gloves but that'll probably change after this thank you oh we've got our little gloves on that's so cute
i don't think i'm sick i think it's like uh maybe dust or something you know so no worries
la la la la oh this way i'm stuck oh oh my god the squirrels oh my god deja vu i think i've been in this place before
little squirrels little squirrels sorry i'm trying to say squirrels
oh it's little body flattened like that I can't at least to stop smoking time to grab the kind of things this job gets me into a baby's gotta do what a baby's gotta do it's not safe to just bring in a piece of germ infected roadkill like this there's a valve container in the car at least then make its odor controllable okay in there and over here right
here what's he doing staring outside were they not concerned about like landslides or anything or where are you going i i gotta go take a leak but the bathroom's right here
What a mess.
The crash shook everything up.
Let's see.
Is there like a dead body in the trunk?
Ah, here it is.
Valved container.
Now to get some of that dirty roadkill.
Okay.
Hand it over.
Contained roadkill odor.
Oh my gosh, it's just like like when they bottle up air and then they sell it.
What is that?
What do we throw?
What is this?
Pain killers?
What's so odd about that?
I carry I carry, like, my ingredients in my purse.
Hmm.
Uh-oh.
Is Neil sick?
I mean, it had to try and run out so that we don't see it.
Oh,
hey.
Did you get the roadkill?
It's ready.
Great!
Go set it up.
I'll be right back.
Neil.
These painkillers.
I think they are yours.
Hey!
May I ask why you are on them?
I wasn't going to tell you, but...
Oh, this is embarrassing.
What's wrong?
A few days ago, I walked into a concrete wall.
You just walked into a wall like that?
What can I say?
I was in deep thought.
You know how deeply I think.
These are some rather strong pills, Neil.
And it was a rather strong concrete wall.
For his IBS.
It is sus.
This is sus.
T'was a match made in heaven, I say.
Anyways.
You got the roadkill, right?
Let's hurry.
John's dying back there.
Aren't we all?
Neil.
You aren't...
Addicted?
Are you...
Are you kidding me?
I'd overdosed before I'd sink to that level of contrived mess.
I didn't even think about that.
Dang, just confronting him.
Are you an addict?
It's not a no.
Oh my gosh, you're right.
All right, give him this smelly squail.
Squirrel.
So when we get to that exact point, I will send the signal.
When I do, I want you to release the valve for about...
three seconds.
You might want to cover your nose, too.
Do-do.
About time you showed up.
Have you made sure the germs are sealed off?
Fully sealed and filtered.
Not like it mattered to a dead man.
He's not dead yet.
We don't want to give him an infection in his last days.
You should know that Johnny's condition is deteriorating fast.
this might be your last chance you two he hates that great flavor whatever you do in there good luck luck's the last thing we need what honestly does it do like I guess it makes them pass on peacefully but like if you fail who's gonna get mad at you Act 3 They shine their lights At the other lighthouses And at me
Welcome to act 3 Thank you Alright This was the soccer ball, right?
Let's go
Can I talk to anybody?
No?
Wait, wait, what?
Oh, they went?
Okay.
Is this the last act?
I'm not quite sure.
To think that this little thing is causing us so much trouble.
I just want to kick it to outer space.
I suppose all we can do now is to send the signal and hope.
Well, ready?
What if you turn the soccer ball into a moon?
Act 3 boss is tough.
Oh!
Sniffle, sniffle!
Something's happening.
Quick, send it again.
Uh-oh.
Doctor, something's wrong.
What?
Take over for me, Lily.
I mean, I would...
His condition has been destabilized.
Intake levels must be reconfigured.
What's happening to this place?
It's been destabilized.
what get out of his memory now what are you talking about if the system doesn't restabilize soon the shock might permanently damage whoever's in here you've got to be kidding me why aren't you getting out then I can't Neil if both of us get out under this state all of our work will be reset there won't be enough time to redo all we've done before Johnny oh you freaking don't pull that contrived crap on me this ain't a movie and you're no hero you're just being a moron it smelled way too bad it smelled so bad he wanted to throw up but couldn't so he's throwing up in his brain then why are you being one too get the hell out of here screw that if you're gone they'll probably pair me with alistair do you know how badly he smells
Worse than the ruin kill!
Oh my god!
Damn it, Liu, this is what I get for helping you cheat through the entrance exams.
She's literally Dr. Watts, don't say that!
He's better now?
Okay, he's better now.
It's fine.
Everything's fine.
Poor Alistair.
I know, right?
Doctor?
I think we're okay for now Too potent
Oh Floody house But this is the same as before Oh and guess what Your carrot cake sucks Wait a minute Yeah and at the last Christmas party you
How do you mess up carrot cake Oh Oh, come on, let's go before that happens again.
Um, you know that I didn't mean to, you know, call you a moron, right?
You know that I did, right?
We're going, we're going, we're going, we're going, we're going.
Wait, so can I just walk on this now?
Is there a place to walk to?
Going down?
We're going down, down.
Then there's nothing around.
Maybe we go back to the ball after all.
I think so, perhaps.
I'm just double-checking.
I think so.
Okay.
Where's the ball?
Oh, there it is.
Here goes nothing.
Oh!
Effort we ball?
Are we here?
Oh my gosh.
We made it!
Wow, I can't believe that worked.
So we actually made it.
But now I'm not sure if I'm going to like this place.
What do you mean?
Seems peaceful enough.
Neil, did you notice something odd in Johnny's room earlier?
Here we go.
Oh gosh, what?
Uh, what?
There was something strange in there.
Did you not see it?
Wait, I don't think I saw it.
I suppose not.
Never mind.
I just hope I'm wrong.
There was something weird?
Wow, that sounds fabulous.
I know, right?
You've got to take them there one day.
Okay.
The moon?
We've got to take them to the moon.
Sheesh, the time overlaps getting out of hand.
Look at how many of them there are.
It's like a zoo.
This is getting out of hand.
Now there's three of them.
Mm-hmm.
Let's check out soccer.
It looks like the ball is moving around on its own and he's just chasing it.
Oh, yeah, it is kind of...
Squail.
I just kind of like that.
Dun, dun.
Oh, wait, I didn't investigate.
Oh, geez.
Look at the time.
I'd better get going.
The store closes early today.
Oh, take care, Martha.
Say hello to the boys for me.
I will.
I'll see you around.
Well, this is the end of the road.
And you were saying...
Never mind that.
Maybe I was wrong after all.
I mean, this place.
It's so peaceful.
The only thing that exists in this memory that could do such a thing would be...
Shit.
Duh.
Wait, what?
We need to go back now.
Wait, what's going on now?
Just shut up and come!
Wait, what?
It's like jaws for real Don't reach out Okay I won't look anymore
I was noticing that he's playing in the street Does he get hit
No Oh my god he just stands there and watches it Oh my god
How fast did you pull out of there Lady!
I don't understand.
If he was unconscious.
How could we be seeing this when...
Seeing this here when he never did.
Still, I'm just surprised that he survived.
I don't think it's...
Okay, wait a second.
I think I made a comment on the bunk beds last time.
I think...
I think this is a...
Actually, he didn't.
Uh, what?
Didn't you see it in his room, Neil?
Johnny slept on a bug bed!
Oh my gosh, I called it!
Oh my gosh!
Joey!
Oh no!
Joey, can you hear me?
Joey and Joey!
Why did you hit Joey, ma?
Oh my god, this is...
Why did you hit him?
Joey, wake up, Joey.
Wake up.
Okay, I thought he was, like, self-inserting himself as the little brother, but I guess they were twins.
No, Joey.
How fast did she pull out of the damn driveway?
Even though they were young.
To lose a twin brother.
Not to mention how their mother must feel.
Doesn't have to be very fast.
What?
I guess that's true.
If you like just keep moving.
You know it's not like a.
Like it doesn't have to be like a.
An impact thing.
I guess it's like a.
Squash.
Maybe.
I don't know.
At least Johnny had the beta blockers erase his memories.
Not like he remembers it much.
Fuzzly unlinked.
Not erased.
Somewhere in there, the aftermath of those memories probably lingered.
What about their mother?
I don't think she took the beta blockers.
She seems to have gone a little cuckoo.
Aww.
Why are you saying like that?
At least I don't really think she called Johnny Joey.
Oh, I forgot about that.
I forgot that she was calling him Joey as a nickname.
And that he said it was like his great-grand- or his grandpa's name or something.
Oh, that's so bad.
But if she then takes Johnny for Joey, what about Johnny himself?
I don't like it here.
Let's move on.
Oh.
Note, Joey.
Seems like this wasn't the only memory unlinked.
Odd.
It's not putting up a barrier anymore.
Don't jinx it.
Oh, there we go.
Dude, you should totally give the series a try.
As a parent, this is my worst nightmare.
Trucks and SUVs keep getting taller and taller.
know i've seen like i've seen like tests where they do where they like put a child height like like figure or something in front of a truck and you can't see it you can't see it some of the trucks are so high you know we should all just drive k trucks and that'll solve the problem
true drive K trucks.
It's the same amount of space in the bed.
I think it's fine.
But yeah.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Okay, there we go.
I mean, really, it's just wicked awesome.
I've already plowed through three books straight.
What's it called?
Animorphs.
That's why he loves animorphs.
Oh my gosh, and that's why his mom gave him the animorphs as a...
As a wedding gift?
It's about this group of kids turning into animals to fight mind-controlling slugs.
Meh.
I don't like that weird alien stuff.
They should Minto-proof the trucks.
Yeah!
I seriously don't know if they would be there.
able to see me.
Why not?
It's great.
Instead of going to boring school, they get to turn into tigers and all big bad aliens.
They're all like, and then they pick up lasers.
And it's all pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Stop that.
Just watch Johnny.
One day, I'm gonna be a famous rider.
novel on the block and every kid will get my book for free beta blockers made them forget his brother but nothing could make him forget anamorphs I think Johnny sort of turned into Joey though because if he's saying he didn't like anamorphs unless he started reading it after you know his brother died I'll make us rich and buy both of you and my really big houses how would you get rich Give away the books for free.
Free for the kids.
The parents still have to pay you, of course.
Yeah, I'm sure the parents will be thrilled to give you money.
What, you're still mad about the other day?
Oh, come on.
I called first dibs on the train.
Fair and square.
What happened to your prize anyway?
I gave it away.
To a hobo?
look it's not just about that day what's going on the kids are fighting you know ma always favored you oh hey that's not true remember last christmas and last easter from the time we went fishing and okay okay you know what you could have my train if you want really yep i mean hey by your Just give me another one,
right?
Listen, Johnny.
What difference does it make?
Who owns what?
Everything that's mine is yours, too.
Aw, you're a sweet little brother.
My...
Michael, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
I mean, we both get to play with it, right?
Yeah.
Right!
I mean, come on, you're my twin brother, dude.
You're like a part of me.
Oi.
Oh, oi.
Let's go confuse the neighbors.
Wait, in the rain?
Yes, in the rain.
Come on.
Animorphs.
Note.
These two are not like Dante and Virgil at all.
is going to be what happened.
Some kind of carnival, huh?
What are the creepy scarecrow?
Shall we look around?
Oh, God, this part?
Okay, I'm not looking.
How about I look around and you just stand here?
How about we continue speaking in the form of questions for the next hour?
Quit blabbering and go already.
Aw, you ruined it.
Hello?
Fruits.
Fresh fruits.
Bulls, oranges, and tomatoes.
We got it all.
Wait a minute.
Tomatoes aren't fruits.
Uh, yeah, they are.
They are the ovaries of the plant and contain seeds.
That's what a fruit is.
But come on, tomatoes!
We never ever refer to them as fruits.
We who?
I happen to enjoy cooking in groups, okay?
Some of us take it very seriously.
Whoa, what's going on here?
Welcome and behold, the world's smallest ferris wheel.
Can we ride it?
Absolutely not.
Does it even work?
Okay.
Looks like someone just glued some chairs to a water wheel.
Don't know, don't care.
What the hell?
I'm looking around.
I saw them over there, by the way.
I'm just looking around first.
Ooh, barbecue!
requires three bars of memory okay just kidding wow i've never seen that before
ferris and twill ferris and twill
but i don't want this stupid toy i want the train that's the only train left do you want to exchange your prize for a teddy bear instead no i just want the train now now john don't make a scene.
Joey won it fair and square, didn't he?
But I won, too.
He just went first.
It's okay.
I'll let you play with it, too.
See how nice your brother is, Johnny.
Okay, you dumplings.
Don't block the stand now.
Come, let's go see what's over there.
I'm not a dumpling.
Johnny's a bit of a downer.
You know what?
I'm going to call you dumpling from now on.
I'm going to call you guys dumpling Dumplings, too.
Dumplings.
You're bluffing.
Dumpling.
Ah, yes.
Fortunes of wonder are ahead of you.
This one might become a lawyer, and this one a doctor.
Oh, my.
Come on, I'm getting both of your treats.
Hey, where's my tip?
Aww, she got both of them treats.
Wait, where'd they go?
Hello?
Uh, I lost them?
Uh.
But I still...
Play whack-a-mole.
Wait, is it in here?
I don't see whack-a-mole.
Unless you're talking about that.
Wait, where'd they go?
Oh, here's the whack-o-oh, can I play it?
Oh, here's the whack-a-mole.
Hey, is that a whack-a-mole?
Whack-a-wha?
Whack-a-mole!
You take a mallet and whack-mole's!
Isn't that animal abuse?
They're fake moles, butt head.
That's how people blew off steam before FPS were invented.
How primitive.
Yeah, it's pretty ghetto.
It's a game.
Where'd you read about it?
My grandpa was a fan.
Wanna play?
Just hit everything on the head?
And you win!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
Yes, I wanna play.
With my mouse.
Okay.
Oh, let's go?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, oh.
They're too fast.
I'm doing it?
Oh, shit.
Sometimes I...
Oh, I clicked out of the game!
Sorry, hold on.
Oh, oh, no, no!
My score!
Stop!
I won, though, right?
Let's see now.
Out of 42 total target appearances, you struck 47 times and made...
38 successful hits.
That's a 90% hit rate!
Okay!
Pretty good.
It's your new record!
Yippee!
Seeds get degrees, baby!
Where's my prize?
Lame, I don't get to keep anything.
Oh, whoops, here.
What's going on here?
So sparkly.
I'm stuck on a bush.
What's going on here?
Oh.
La la la la la la.
This looks so fine.
I want to go to a festival.
Made mint March May.
It's November.
We want to go to the festival.
Okay, let's go talk to them.
Imagine if you went into a dying person's memories and came out with balloons and prizes.
right?
I can never understand you, Joey.
How can you stand the taste of them?
They're just so sour and icky.
Sour and awesome is what you mean.
Just try it.
Nah, I don't even want to taste regular.
The olives.
Oh my gosh, he really did just become Joey.
I don't even want to taste regular olives.
You should try at least one, Johnny.
Who knows, maybe I'll like it.
Yeah!
He got gaslit so hard!
Nah!
I'm done, though.
Can I go play?
Okay, but only at the playground and not an inch too far.
Just leave that bag.
I'll keep it for you.
No, it's mine.
I want it!
Pickled olives.
No stinking way!
He didn't even like olives.
What's he gonna give it to?
What do you get, I wonder?
Venom Joey.
All things lead back to Metal Gear.
Where's he going?
Way to follow mom's orders, huh?
Where are we going?
Ooh, this looks like a date.
Why does this look similar to...
like where the what's it called is the lighthouse
he's gonna get abducted wow don't reach out okay thank you
birds whoa birds
Wow, whoa!
Well, okay, so he wandered off at the trail and found a cool place.
Let's face it, he could have also been eaten by a pack of tigers.
Tigers don't travel in packs, idiot.
It was just an expression.
You know, when I was a kid, my grandpa took me stargazing every year.
Yeah?
There was a hill outside of the city that we'd stay at.
The same one every year.
We'd watch the stars till daybreak.
Well, I did mostly.
He just carried the telescope for me.
Of course.
The thing was, though, Ma didn't want me to stay up late.
Grandpa always...
Why does everybody say ma?
Grandpa always told her that we were just camping and hid the telescope inside the car.
Well, you can't bring a telescope to the car?
Or to camping?
Their southerners must be the south.
That's all good, but when we got back in the morning, I had to pretend like I'd actually slept.
So in conclusion, that's the story of how I started my caffeine addiction.
You're terrible.
I know.
It's a shame, though.
Wow.
All these nice memories lost and never found.
And who knows how many more like it?
Well, as you say, just take it moment for moment, right?
Mm-hmm.
Oh.
I told you packs of tigers dwell here.
What is it?
Someone else walking.
The tigers have shoes.
Ah!
Of course!
River.
Wait, don't go!
Tiger, I'm Johnny.
What's your name?
They're at my spot.
Their spot.
She's mad at you.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to hog this place all to myself.
Aw, Johnny's a little good kid.
Um, you wanna join me?
Watch the stars.
Are you?
Their first encounter.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, did we...
We got a CG!
Oh my gosh.
Our first CG.
Just look at them.
It's a thumbnail.
Did you know?
There were so many lights in the sky Yes, oh, I did too
You said this was your spot right only during the carnival not a fan of the crowds Me neither you know you still haven't told me your name yet I'm not telling you everyone makes fun of it in school.
No, but it's That's cute!
Why?
They say it makes them want to go to the washroom.
Uh, okay then.
Well, it can't be worse than John.
I mean, everywhere in the world, nearly everyone's named John.
Even in India?
All those Johns in India.
Probably.
Wait, so he met her and then forgot about it, but still lied to her.
when he met her again why didn't she ever bring it up then what's wrong with that
what's wrong with having a name that everyone has well it's boring i guess i mean if everyone has it then what's the point i wouldn't mind just for once to have the same name as everyone else
It's like those lights in the sky.
They all look the same from here, but that doesn't make them any less pretty.
I suppose.
River's name makes the want to go to the John.
I could really use a wish right now.
A wish right now.
What do you think those stars up...
Wait, what do you think those stars up there are anyway?
says they're giant burning spheres of gas oh I bet he's just making it up why would he lie to me because you know that's what grown-ups do they make things up Santa Easter Bunny kangaroos stuff like that I wish kangaroos were real have you ever made an Easter Bunny out of stars like a constellation Yes.
Of the other things?
Never tried a rabbit, though.
Santa's not real?
Yeah, you can't convince me that he's not real.
Do you want to make one?
Yeah, we'll make the fastest constellation ever.
Let's see who makes one out first.
Who makes one out first?
Okay, we'll start in three.
Wait, do I have to do this for real?
Three, two, one.
And I see it.
Where?
In the sky.
But where in the sky?
Think big.
I'm trying to see the big picture.
Bigger than all the others.
Is it the bunny on the moon?
Wait a minute.
minute i see it tell me what you see isn't this how she would talk about the bunny the or the origami bunnies there right there's the two ears and head what else and there oh my god wait oh my gosh when she was doing that was she trying to get him to remember
There, there's, there, it's two feet.
Yes, what else?
And the moon!
The moon is its big round belly.
So what do you think they really are?
The stars, I mean.
I...
I never told anyone, but...
I've always thought they were light.
Billions of lighthouses stuck at the far end of the sky.
Wow, it must be so lively up there.
But it isn't.
They can see all the other lighthouses out there, but they want to talk to them.
Oh, and they want to talk to them.
But they can't because they're all too far apart to hear what the others are saying.
All they can do is shine their lights for them.
a far so that's what they do they shine their lights at the other lighthouses and that me why you because one day I'm going to befriend one of them that bag what's in it oh no it's the prize I won from whack-a-mole did you get to play that game i tried but i'm too clumsy what did you get from it i got a thing i don't really know what it is it's the platypus it's
some kind of a weird duck beaver thing may i see it
It looks so strange.
I wish I could win one myself.
Eek!
That's my calling.
You know what?
Keep it.
It's yours.
Mine?
Yeah, I can always get another.
I don't like to brag, but I'm totally the best at that game.
Will you be here next year?
Yep, will you?
Same place, same time?
Why did he jump like that?
What if you forget or get lost?
Then we can always regroup on the moon, silly!
Right on the rabbit's tummy!
Me, coming!
Oh yeah, I forgot my hacky sack in the bag.
You said you're clumsy, right?
Maybe it'll help.
Accusack.
Because that was the one that she tried to like almost jump off the cliff for, right?
If they ever get lost.
Wait, does that mean?
Don't tell me you didn't see that coming.
And here I thought this was gonna be an inspirational childhood dream story.
Maybe I should have known that some girl would come along and turn it into a cheese fest.
I suppose now we know what we must do to send them to the moon.
Wait, you aren't actually going to do it, are you?
That's our job, Neil.
It's what we are contracted to do.
Damn it, Eva, wait!
Eva.
They just wouldn't be nice.
On the moon!
Uh...
I know you are in here!
Stop to it, Bladipus.
This is all your fault!
What?
Wait, why?
Scary music.
Be-beam.
Be-beam-beam.
Oh, there she is.
Turn around.
I know what you are planning to do.
I know that you know.
Yeah?
Well, I know that you know that.
Look, our contract is to send him to the moon.
And the only way for that to happen is if Johnny is motivated to do so.
But if that means removing River, then what's the point?
Yeah.
The reason why he even wants to go to the moon in the first place is because she died.
bound by the contract to specifically screw the contract wait why would you i didn't take this job to make him miserable eva i don't know about you but i signed up to help the freaking geysers die happy me too and i like this job but if we directly go against our legal obligations we'd be in for court hearings we'll appeal we know that johnny'd be happier to not go to the moon There's a lot of alternate life tangents,
Neal.
Oh my gosh, wait!
Why, why does she turn so bad?
Why is Neal so good now?
By who, who would sue?
I know, right?
How would they know?
We're not here to play God.
Our job is to give him what he signed for.
Well, we happen to know what he wants better than he does.
Look, I'm only risking losing River because I believe in her.
What do you mean, risk?
You're removing her!
And besides, I will make up for it.
Make up for it?
How?
Uh-oh.
We're unstable.
We're running out of time.
Oh my god, no!
Eva's choosing the mission.
Just trust me.
Oh my god.
Says the one who pushed me off the freaking lighthouse!
Already 19.
Thank you!
Did you just...
Wait.
What's happening?
Oh my god.
Freaking light data.
Abusing your powers doesn't disable my controls entirely, Eva.
Oh, now it's a horror game.
Oh my god.
Booby traps!
Really, Eva?
Just trying to buy some time.
Gee, thanks for telling me.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Those are some expensive pieces of equipment you're tossing.
Seriously, just stay put.
until I'm done.
Oh, piss off.
Yeah.
Wait.
Look, don't make me exit this whole thing and unplug you.
Would you really risk distorting his memories as they are?
Just stop trying, please.
This won't take long.
Not again.
Or come and find me at the end of the hall.
Suddenly, oh, suddenly I'm playing like a real RPG.
Baker game.
What the?
Oh my god.
Did she create a zombie versions of herself?
Is this a game to you, Eva?
Zombie evas.
Dear Lord, they aren't just zombie evas.
They're zombie evas.
Oh my god.
Don't come any closer.
I got plants.
Wait, what do I see?
Oh.
What the heck?
What is happening?
Oh my god, I'm subtly shooting.
Oh, oopsie.
Ah!
How do I get up there?
I go around?
Oh, she's at the end of the hall, right?
These things are good for something after all!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, oops.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh, there's so many!
Ah!
Final boss!
Why am I going through a looping hallway anyway?
Oh my god, why are there boulders now?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Oh gosh!
Two steps forward, five steps back.
Oh, screw this.
Yeah.
Oh.
PT hallway.
What the?
I'm not sure if there's an actual time limit or not.
So I go this way.
Oh.
Eva?
What happened?
I know.
What character development?
What else?
Billions of light?
is stuck at the far end of the sky.
Now the whole construct's messed up.
Oh my god.
It did become a little bit like a horror game.
Oh, what the...
Oh, the bunny.
It's finished, River.
She won't be alone anymore.
The lighthouse, Anya!
What did they build to make her not lonely?
I just don't want to be another typical kid and to see if typical people, Nick.
What is it like?
Just the responsibilities, I suppose.
Oh yeah, after they got married.
Is that what the home was supposed to be, the place I built?
Oh.
Oh, everything...
It'll help you understand her condition.
I'd rather not.
Why is that?
Why?
Everything's all freaky.
Oh, gosh, it scared me.
Oh, they're dancing together though!
Let's jump scare.
Emperor's new clouds!
Hello!
Wait, don't call!
I'm Johnny, what's your name?
Oh gosh, spooky.
This is so spooky.
Look, it was a long time ago.
There's no date or time, Johnny.
What's that mean?
Oh, I'm in the dark.
Oh, why is it so dark?
Okay, we're fine.
This is our game all of a sudden.
Hello, Neil.
Morpheus?
What?
It's Eva, you idiot.
We're the only ones here.
Listen, whatever you've been doing, stop it.
Colonel.
Minty is probably.
We might not know what Johnny wants, but we know what he doesn't want.
And what he doesn't want is exactly what you are accelerating.
It's already done, Neil.
Why don't you come out now?
What?
Oh, the shadow people took her away.
What color are those pain pills, Neal?
I know, right?
Silent Hill F up here.
What did you do to her?
Relax, she's merely going somewhere else.
You know, it's one thing to disable by control is to feed me some olives.
But this is way out of line.
I'm sorry, but this just won't go anywhere if you keep on resetting the memory.
At this point, this is the only way.
asking you to trust me.
So please, just calm down and wait here.
I don't understand why they couldn't...
They brought back his older memories.
So, like, why couldn't they just have him remember that?
And then it would make him want to go to the moon.
Or, like, if they can alter memories at all, why don't they make it so that he remembers the...
earlier stuff and then forgets about his brother still or something.
I don't know.
Does it have to be linked?
Is that the thing?
Please just calm down and wait here.
Then just pull the trigger already.
Where are you going?
Yeah, let's find out!
There's just one last thing I need to do.
Poser.
There's no need to visualize a door.
What's with all this melodrama, Neil?
waiting so hard for this.
Forget it.
There's no time.
Everything will be alright, man.
Just turn around.
Okay.
Hey, what are you?
Oh, she's not there.
Ahem, hello!
Sorry, kid.
It's already started.
Come
on, they're going to hog all the good tables.
They're all the same.
Sheesh.
Aw.
Uh.
Joey's right.
The ones by the kitchen smell better.
Totally.
And all the refills are just steps away.
Ah, olives.
Saving him doesn't justify it.
another river Neil she completely forgot the point of why he wanted to go to the moon you
if I doing this you essentially kill another person but he'll only have one brother come on we're in the way it is not reality that's true but it's like his reality it's it's his memories and all
short steps whoa vocals chin up I can't step into the spotlight she said I'm sad somehow without any words I just stood there searching for an answer when this world is no more the moon is all we'll see don't say astronaut to fly away with me until the stars all fall down the sky but if you're with me then everything's all right oh my god the nasa poster
why do my words always lose their meaning what i feel what i say there's the one who won this time
They don't even go to the carnival.
I just stood there.
Never know what I should do.
When this world is no more, the moon is all we'll see.
I'll ask you to fly away with me Until the stars all fall down Whoa!
They empty from the sky He became the author!
He's like he's wanted to If you're with me He's bro Animorphs!
Everything's alright
with me.
Nanomorphs too.
Oh.
NASA!
He actually made it, huh?
You sound surprised.
Whatever happened to, we always succeed because we are awesome.
To the moon, I guess.
This isn't a success.
Oh, lighten up.
We don't have much time left.
Let's at least check this place out.
I like how we create a memory link, but it's all fake.
Please wait here.
Someone will come and show you around shortly.
Me and my NASA desk.
To the moon.
A story about a lame duck's attempt to become an astronaut.
A novel by Joey Wiles.
I can't believe this crap actually is.
actually sold.
This isn't the real world, Neil.
How pathetic all this trouble just for some girl.
That's what I thought you'd say, Neil.
There you go.
Good to have you back.
Yeah, yeah.
Wow, Nasha, this is what it looks like for real.
Four bars, okay.
Is it me or is this elevator smaller on the inside?
Oh, oh, uh, two?
Wait, where are we at now?
We were at one, right?
Soul official NASA business.
This is the Mission Control Center.
Wow.
Not much going on now, but you'll see it live one day.
Like, so he just...
He just, like, mailed Nassau.
He just kept mailing Nassau and was like, let me in?
Is this a job?
Is this an internship?
I half expected to see Zordon on that screen.
It's not here.
Uh, what?
Let's just go.
Did he, like, program...
to meet...
River at NASA or something.
Is that what we're doing?
They're co-workers?
So what do you...
So do you think last century's moon landing was...
Let's not, Neil.
Let's not.
Your records are excellent, but we'll have to monitor your status closely in the coming sessions.
Sorry.
And here's the centrifuge.
If you're lucky, you'll learn to hate it one day.
Ah, yes, the spinny thingy.
It's not here either.
What are you talking about?
Come on, we don't have long left.
Okay.
I'm looking around.
I want to ride it.
I yawn, sorry.
So sorry.
Moon.
Moon, moon.
Oh, gosh.
Gosh, we'll try to click the thing.
I hope the real NASA has bigger elevators.
The shuttle's still under heavy maintenance.
We may only view it from here for now.
Oh, this isn't good.
Perhaps there's something, somewhere we missed.
You need to work on your communication skills.
Oh, hello, hello.
Nyaru, thank you so much for the radar act.
so much for that gift thank you so much thank you thank you we're kind of like at the end of this game so it might be some spoilers for to the moon if you have not played thank you ashen thank you combo thank you cc thank you thank you thank you thank you boulder bird thank you now well thank you fireball thank you thank you guys for all the gift thank you thank you thank you thank you pretty sad so Rust and glitch race thank you Whimsy thank you thank you guys thank you so much oh requires red memory length to put oh do I go look whoa wow I said it first you you you you thank you wrong for rabbit there wait no you're just wrong rabbit what happened to the four thank you
Thank you guys so much.
You are Neil.
I have more Neilisms than I realize.
It's not in the ad.
No!
You're always wrong for Rabbit to me.
YouTube ate it.
You know what's the best part of it?
What?
The very top and bottom of the shuttle.
I'd have to agree.
Oh, how I pity anyone who can't see those particular parts indeed especially its nose at the top when maintenance finishes it probably won't look the same yeah now's the only time rude they made us look at that so we could leave through the door they were like hey you have to see this really funny bit we put in it was the first floor right okay so you evil.
Taxido can't thank you.
Good bit.
I wonder if the real NASA looks like this.
Probably not.
It's constructed in part with Johnny's beliefs after all.
Ah yes, a wiki of existing facts tainted by personal fairy tales.
It's odd though to hear birds and see none.
Sorry, Neil.
I really thought there was a good chance.
What?
And this is the break room.
Maybe don't reach out for the next two minutes.
I received a gift.
Sorry, I don't control them, but maybe one day you will be one of the lucky chosen.
I think it's all random.
Here's David.
He's a mission specialist.
Nice to meet you.
At least he got into NASA, I guess.
You think he made it to the end?
Even if he did, it'd take more than just a few years to become an astronaut.
Let's hurry and find the last link then.
I'd hate to miss the finale.
Oh.
What's going on?
Are we out of time?
I don't know.
And here's our other new recruit!
River, right?
Good to have you on board.
Hello, I'm John.
I almost thought she was...
What the?
Viva!
But you deleted her!
No, I told you, I just moved her.
I knew it, I knew it!
I knew she'd be here.
What she does with her life here is still up to her.
But this new world is based on public data and Johnny's own beliefs.
And since River's data as an individual is not recorded in the public domain, it all comes from Johnny.
But even then, that merely increases the odds.
How are you sure that it'd work?
I wasn't.
It could have gone very badly, you know.
It sucks that.
They lost all those memories together, but...
I guess, you know.
It's still nice that they meet it all.
You were never one to take risks, Neil.
Let's just say I won this round.
We still have two spare helmets.
right I think John need to appreciate some company they
do sell the rest of their lives after this so true the heartbeat
he wrote it himself apparently rather repetitive if you ask me though everyone's a critic what's it called To the boon!
I like that name.
What it used to be for you!
It's meant for you!
Her side eye.
Whoa.
Everybody's getting in on the helmets.
Okay.
Crazy.
Who's watching the kids?
Oh.
Oh, there you are.
You two should go get some rest.
Tomorrow's the big day.
Oh, look at them.
If I were going into space, I think I'd shave my head.
I wouldn't want to deal with my hair.
Hudson River.
Oh my god!
Oh.
Bald Minto confirmed.
I want to be an astronaut too, Dad!
One day, son, you just might.
Shut up fake child.
Oh!
did you think that they would make it ha did you no the way she is I didn't think she would succeed but I I guess I was wrong all the better then isn't it yes I'm happy for them you should have seen him back when we were went to school together I swear the guy never arrested him he just kept on trying and trying It was like he only had one goal to work for.
You know, that's my brother in that shuttle.
Wow!
Yep, I once wrote a book about this, too.
Oh, good luck with your move.
With a less optimistic ending.
Might have to change that after all.
Hey, Dr. Watts, right?
Thank you for letting us in here.
Yeah, Eva's the one who requested it.
Was she?
I don't actually remember who brought up the two extra helmets.
Did you find out why he wanted to go to the moon?
Sure.
And what all happened here?
Let's just say it was a bunch of sappy cheese that sorted itself out.
You know, there were quite a few times last night when I thought we lost it.
Johnny.
I think he consciously held on to wait for you too.
He's rather patient then.
I just hope it's worth the wait.
Go on now, your colleagues waiting.
Whoa!
I thought this might be a good view.
Good enough to cut off the traffic, eh?
Sure, even if they were real.
Well, this is it.
All we've worked for ready to initiate
initiate come up here why why not you're just gonna push me off the ledge again aren't you probably but the view is worth the odds
come on
oh my gosh mission control whoa we're seeing It happened!
We're seeing it live!
Oh my gosh, the team!
Oh my gosh, they're in the shuttle!
Oh!
I have to
make it first!
Because one day I'm going to befriend one of them.
Oh!
Watch out birds!
Get out of the way!
Yeah, I didn't really ship them, so...
So the memories come back?
Oh, the simulation is breaking.
Oh
Her side eye the last side eye
It's so bittersweet
I would be so pissed if someone reprogrammed my memories to just have me be studying my whole life.
I would be so mad.
How dare you do that to me?
How dare you make me do science don't work?
Emily was in the credits?
I didn't see it.
Yeah, but you'd be so smart.
And then I wouldn't be a V-tuber.
Here he is.
Thanks.
Off you go now.
I don't want to read.
I still can't believe Johnny just wheeled the house to Lily like that.
Why?
What do you mean you can't believe that?
Who else was there to give it to?
Us?
Terrible place for burials, though.
If there's a landslide, they'd be swimming with the fishes.
Still a little too soon.
Nah, it's never soon enough.
Nice new ringtone.
Wait, we never heard about his painkiller or stuff.
Hello, Eva here.
We're on our way.
New patient, new patient.
Let's roll.
The ending still gets beach time.
That's so good.
What was that?
Spooky.
So there, that would be the...
So it's a prequel and then a sequel.
That exists.
I don't know though.
I feel like I got so invested in Johnny and River that...
I don't know.
Oh.
It was so sweet.
I can't believe everything was just her trying to get him to remember.
Makes me so sad.
Oh, took me out from the music.
Thank you for being a part of this adventure.
The story continues.
Finding Paradise.
Imposter Factory.
Whoa.
Sussy.
When the game is sus.
When the factory is sus.
The other games in this franchise are good but not as hard hitting to me.
Though the music in all of them is peak.
Bird!
Wish my life away also made me cry.
I don't know that one.
Congrats, I'm finishing this beautiful game.
Thank you!
What makes me so sad about it too though is...
The lighthouse is still lonely.
In the new memory.
New game plus.
What was the vocal song called in this game?
Lily will be there.
No, I meant in the... I guess in the fabricated memory.
That's not real.
I don't know.
Oh, everything's alright.
Oh, that I gotta blow my nose.
Don't mute.
Sorry, too late.
Should we add everything's alright too?
Karaoke.
Maybe I'll, maybe next time.
Virtual Joey can live in the Virtual Lighthouse.
I guess, I guess honestly, what...
What...
Um...
Sorry.
What Eva constructed was maybe like the quote-unquote best possible events that could have been in his life or something, you know.
Maybe.
It came with a risk.
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
I mean, it did kind of like erase his purpose for going to the moon.
But if he remembered in the end.
If he remembered right before it ended anyway.
So, um, I don't want to be that person, but he didn't actually go to the moon.
They didn't make it.
Laura Shikihara who did the music and sang in the games is the same as my plans versus zombies oh my gosh like the zombie on your lawn song thanks for the streaming tell revisiting the story always gets me i'm so glad i played it it's so pretty hope you enjoyed my favorite canadian indie game it was so nice yeah wow
well i guess the game is called to the moon.
It's not called on the moon, so...
Technically he did.
All the memories afterwards played up till... Oh, that's true.
They only watched the launching.
That's true.
That is true.
There's something Neil would... That's something Neil would say.
Oh, I'm so glad I played it.
cry though i was trying to be strong what made me cry oh the whole like revelation about it made me so about her just trying to get him to remember everything it's too the kid clips in about the memories is sad i know it's so sad dargo thank you so much for that guys feeling conflicted so a Joey apparently smell like day-old roadkill right now.
No, there was a squirrel, though.
There was a squirrel at the bottom.
I think he was... I think he connected that memory.
Two, is the final paper rabbit weird for wearing clothes, or are the rest weird for being naked?
That's a light-hearted question.
The bomb probably hit that squirrel, too.
I think she needs glasses.
As a reminder, River and John still met when they were young children.
That's why River had to go poo for the rest of it.
He was looking for her.
They did meet on the moon.
You can think of a morbid answer for that.
Is it because when you die, you poop your pants?
It didn't happen to me, though.
different.
I can't have you guys thinking about me like that.
Thanks for letting us know boss, of course.
Just trying to lighten the mood up a little bit while I have tears streaming down my face.
All that for just some girl.
I'm different is wild.
She fasted for 48 hours.
Oh gosh.
Her butt stays sledge.
What a sweet kid.
Oh.
I was getting nachos.
Say the funny thing again.
The need for brown super jets.
Don't say that.
Honestly, though, if I were in this situation, I don't know which I would want.
Like, I guess technically they fulfilled his dream and also gave his brother a life.
And he still met River in the end.
But...
All the original memories, too.
They're all so precious, you know.
I always wondered why there was chocolate on her leg.
Don't say that.
Don't wonder that either.
Tissue buns for me, though.
I've wasted...
Thank you.
Oh.
All the memories of him eating olives.
Oh, gosh.
You know what?
Maybe the new ones were better.
He wasted years without the woman he loved, so I think the new timeline is an L.
I agree.
Your IBS kept you from pooping.
No, I don't think that's what IBS does.
It's the opposite, no?
Such an amoe game.
Thank you for the stream.
Thank you!
The real despair is that River died never knowing why John forgot about their first meeting.
I didn't think about that.
Unless...
She might have known that he had a brother.
She might have known that he had a brother and then the brother disappeared.
She, but maybe, I don't know.
I guess not, right?
And her just trying to get him to remember just really breaks my heart.
Because, you know, she gives him the little paper bunny.
And she's, like, asking him what he sees.
And if even when I was playing that part, I was feeling like a little frustrated like I don't know he's describing the bunny.
What do you expect?
Just thinking it was her being kind of quirky
But then also What triggered that was the dead bunny that like the the bunny road kill so I wonder if she put two and two together or something
I wonder Hmm
It was him saying he dated her for clout.
Oh, that's right.
Wait, or was that what triggered it?
Oh, I guess you're right, yeah.
But then she knows that that's not...
She like knows in her heart that's not the real reason.
Yeah, it all comes back to the roadkill.
No!
I've been taking walks.
Like, recently on my way, walks I've been finding like dead baby snakes is it I'm like why are there so many snakes first of all it's so strange all these little snakes just saw one today oh my gosh I think it must have been so heartbreaking to watch him throw the hacky sack like it was nothing yeah everything meant something to her everything meant something to her and to him he couldn't remember why she had the platypus why why about the bunnies why about the hacky sack how much that meaning meant to her how she probably felt so seen like talking to him about everything and how it resonated with her so much i
just i saw an interpretation of that very last scene of johnny and river as i'm meeting in heaven him giving her the platypus is a way of saying he remembered her this game always made me cry so happy you played it it made me cry too she cut her hair afterwards so that she had the same hairstyle as when they first i didn't think about that oh my gosh no no
I choose that ending.
I keep almost tripping over deer.
Oh, they're alive and kicking, though.
Oh my gosh.
The more one thinks the sadder the game gets.
Terrible day for brain.
She tried so hard.
She did.
My favorite part is that Johnny's belief in her memories place her at nasa too oh that's true
we ever probably realized johnny didn't remember their first meeting he didn't know what the hacky sack or platypus meant so much to her that must have hurt she couldn't express it either yeah
so sad the beta blockers
I wonder if That was His choice As a child You don't really have Like If If his mom sort of forced him to do that It was definitely the moms I think I think so I
think robbing his desire of the meaning behind it makes it a bit hollow.
Technically, that fulfilled the contract.
But if he didn't remember Rabbit Tummy, was it really worth it?
Good late Tum Tum Day.
Yeah.
That's how I feel about it.
I think that's why it's also very bittersweet of an ending.
Because it does kind of...
The meaning of going to the moon...
Was a little lost.
Mom was the villain Honestly
Acceptance as much as resolution
Like the moral ambiguity of the concept of destroying a dying person's memories and replacing them with better ones Moments before they're destroyed anyway It's a very interesting concept
Like What to be at peace What?
Where were you guys when I died?
Not you guys, but like the company.
Both garter snakes and diamond backs have eggs that hatch internally, which mean they have a sort of live birth instead of laying eggs.
Wait, Kinky!
How are, like, your bees and stuff?
Bees!
Please!
Please.
Maybe you being a bee tuber is them doing their job.
We're in a simulation.
You guys kinky is a beekeeper.
And it's been a while since I've heard about it.
So I was just asking.
Trying to be nice.
And I'm curious.
Unfortunately, I lost both of my hives!
This year after a family crisis when next year will be better.
I'm sure thanks for asking though.
No!
No, it's a peace.
I hope everything's okay.
All bad news all around.
Knockers, stop crying, the floodgates.
Quick!
out uh oh my gosh i'll like i'll like watch a i'll watch tick tock later and it'll be like here's a grandpa and he's playing the violin for his for his dead wife one last time and i'll
And then if floodgates just, they're already open, I'll just...
Please play the other games, they're worth it.
Are they about the same length as this one?
I'm definitely interested in checking them out, so...
Yeah, about the same?
Similar but longer.
Okay,
okay.
Okay, okay.
More RPG Maker.
I love RPG Maker games.
Oh, actually I love RPG Maker games.
Like horror RPG Maker games.
Those are kind of my jam.
Oh, I should maybe play some of those to get out, to knock games out for me trying to be 50 games this year.
On the bright side, my beef stew came out pretty good.
Let's go!
Yeah, we take those!
Check out the mini-sodes.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I've played I played Witch's House more recently than not.
I feel like I could play eeb but I remember so I played eeb a ton so I remember so much of it still what else is there's like hanged man those are all the classics last from the past one point yeah yeah that's what I'm talking about which is house for back then so that was one of my first games I played on my channel actually which is house oh crooked man that's what I was thinking yeah thank you I said hanged man Sorry,
thinking of the game.
Mad Father!
I feel like I played that one not so long ago, too.
Do you ever play Chrono Trigger?
Wondering if this game got you triggered at parts like the rest of us.
I haven't!
I want to, though.
Mogeko Casual.
I don't know that one.
RPG Maker Horror Games can be completed quickly.
Could play the Black Souls series.
Streamer Safe editions, of course.
What's the not streamer?
I feel like Chrono Trigger is one of those games that like...
It's like one of those RPG games that like...
It's like quintessential.
You know?
It's a classic.
I broke my Tetra record again this dream!
Let's go!
I think I play better when I'm in pain.
It's like 30 hours.
Oh my gosh.
Our JRPGs tend to be that way.
That's why it's really tough sometimes.
I would like to try it, though.
I would.
But guys.
I gotta go pack.
I gotta go finish packing.
Oh, too mean.
Don't go to Trigger being longer, 20 hours apart.
It's what made me learn English.
So I would love it if it ever happened.
Oh my gosh, Karateka!
Wait, that's so awesome!
That's so cool.
Yeah, safe travels.
Thank you.
I am a little nervous.
I'm not gonna lie.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Sago!
Oh!
Happy birthday!
BHD Killers!
My birthday was yesterday.
Can I get a Vito week?
Happy birthday!
Have a good trip, Minky.
Don't overwork yourself.
Thank you.
I'll be back Tuesday.
Tuesday to stream.
No, no, sorry.
Sorry.
I said I would stream Friday, Saturday, Sunday.
Friday, Saturday, Sunday.
I will stream.
Or at least one of those days.
If not all three.
At least one.
Maybe all three.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Safe travels.
Take your time, boss.
Don't leave anything important.
Thank you.
Bon voyage, boss.
Bon voyage.
I will see you next when I see you next.
Yeah.
And I guess maybe since I'll be on my laptop, we could play something kind of easy.
Maybe it will be.
end up being an RPG horror game or something.
Otsubito!
Thank you, everybody!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Iterasha!
Thank you so much for suggesting to the moon.
Everybody who did.
I really, really enjoyed it.
I'm glad we could...
I'm glad we could play it together.
Also, I've never heard you say moe, moe, boo!
I say it all the time.
What are you talking about?
Bye-bye!
Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, see you, see you in a couple days, see you in a couple days, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, see you in a couple days, bye, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see, see,
see, see, see, see, see,